la consommation d'énergie est en Haus et
cela se ressent pour les usagers qui
voient leur facture augmenté les
livreurs de fi font le plein les
livraisons pour les particuliers selon
certaines études de rbondi de 40 % en
mars par rapport à l'année dernière de
20 % en mai tout cela à cause du mauvais
temps bien sûr cler Cambier et lodim
moine pluie brouillard averse crach à in
tempéri appelez-le comme vous voulez le
mauvais temps persiste depuis des mois
parapluies et coupevent ont volé la
dettes au parasol et aux lunettes de
soleil si certains refusent de rallumer
le chauffage d'autres ivelinois S sont
résignés et craignent que ce soit leur
portefeuille qui chauffe de toute façon
moi j'ai un chauffage collectif donc oui
il est allumé et voilà j'ai pas le choix
mais tant mieux qu'on en est il y aura
une incidence sur le loyer bah sur les
charges en fin d'année ou oui pas de
problème on y aura le droit aussi je
dirais au moins 100 à 150 € par de plus
pour l'année quoi les livreurs de fi ne
désemplissent pas leur carnet de
commande depuis l'hiver côté
consommation électrique la hausse reste
modérée on a en Île-de-France un
surcroix de consommation électrique qui
est assez modeste qui est de l'ordre de
3 % alors que sur l'ensemble de la
France on serait plutôt à plus 5 % voire
même plus 10 % à certains moment alors
en Île de France c'est moindre parce
qu'on est au nord de la Loire où il y a
une influence océanique qui fait que les
printemps sont un peu plus frais de
toute façon dans la région parisienne
que dans le sud de la Loire et le
chauffage électrique est plus répandu au
Sud également que au nord de la France
comptez tout de même pour votre
prochaine facture une hausse de 10 à 100
€. pour les adeptes du chauffage au gaz
qui connaissent les mêmes difficultés on
note heureusement une prochaine baisse
du prix de 0,6 % le 1er juin les
particuliers ne sont pas les seuls à
trinquer même les administrations sont
concernées la communauté d'agglomération
contactée aujourd'hui indique que leurs
radiateurs sont rallumer à minima le
matin une première en
mai et justement êtes-vous inquiet pour
vos factures avez-vous déjà du mal à
régler ces additions quelques réactions
au micro dès le di moine c'est notre
question du jour non en fait j'utilise
pas quasiment le sauvage parce que bon
c'est vrai que il faut faire attention
aussi à à la planète on facture bien sûr
oui il 20 à 30 € de plus je pense he je
je je le saurai d'ici un mois enfin je
sais pas après il faut voir ce que ça va
donner sur les factures quoi mais dans
l'immédiat non tant que je suis au chaud
c'est le principal je pense que quand
même c'est quand même untit peu
inquiétant bah il est fermé déjà je mets
des chaussettes